I was going to say Ted we also have wine
and donuts that sounds great but wine
lovers are getting warmed up for a
Cabernet Sauvignon Smackdown it's going
down tomorrow at SW Steakhouse inside
the wind and Brian Whiteman With the
Wind you're here to kind of tell us the
game plan that's right yeah exactly
because when I think Smackdown I think
wrestling not wine so please explain
what is happening at this event
first of all thank you for having me so
Napa Valley is really known for Cabernet
Sauvignon but Washington state has been
making great wines for decades now okay
so it's the battle of the areas right we
love to create master classes with a lot
of guest participation so the guests are
going to decide who's making the best
Cabernet right now ooh now what do you
think since you are you know the expert
who's wrong
understood understood now there is also
a special NFL Hall of Famer that's
joining you what's his relationship with
the wine so I mean to lay out how the
class is good to go
we'll welcome people in start them off
with a glass of champagne they're making
them all warmed up we're going to get
them in the mood definitely and then
we're gonna have Jeff who's our senior
wine manager and Drew Bledsoe who's our
special guest and they will go head to
head and Pitch four different flights
two wines each one from Napa and one
from Washington
and
let the guests decide what's you know
what the best watches are so it's more
than just tasting though you're also
learning about the wines kind of an
educational experience too yeah
definitely yeah I mean we'll definitely
get into what makes parts of the Napa
unique and what the why where the lines
come from from Napa and Washington right
because within those two areas you have
many different growing sub-regions I'll
say so much goes into it that are really
unique and then even after the wine
there's a lot of wines to taste it's
maybe between eight to ten wines so I
have everyone wash it down with some
sliders okay I was going to ask is their
food
Steakhouse there better be some food um
now how does everyone get involved or
get tickets because this is for anyone
wine lovers you are invited 21 and over
absolutely absolutely yes anyone of age
they can go we have very limited like
really limited tickets right now as it
is tomorrow okay but going on The Win
Las vegas.com website going under
experiences Tab and all the information
informations there to book okay perfect
you can't make this one there's tons of
other experience
Kendall I'll send it to you all right